mr. money asks what do you consider more
about enthusiasm or mr. money before I
answer your question let me ask you a
question everyone get a name like mr.
money that feels a pretty remarkable you
know I carry money I like it anyway
action or enthusiasm the truth is my
friend M Squared can I call you that mr.
money the real answer to that question
really is both the funny thing is I know
tons of people with massive enthusiasm
and they can't execute dick on the flip
side I know people that can execute a's
on all their papers but without that
passion or bravado or fire they're only
able to get limited return on that
investment of execution so to me I'm
probably a 60/40 action execution 60
enthusiasm 40 I know a lot of people
might not get that but the truth is I'm
Way more proud of my execution skills
all this all this charisma hides what I
really am which is a hardcore executor
don't forget I executed a large business
before I ever hit the scene
I was already 30 years old I started
Wine Library TV and started that whole
process and so I'm a 60/40 execution
enthusiasm action I might even be a 6535
heck as I sit here maybe I'm a 70/30